to preserve the Award for Best Picture
are you guys done yet
go ahead
the present award for next picture we
have an actor whose presence has made
many of them oh whether he's in plastics
or a dress he's always in a dress oh no
sorry
there's no mistaking the talent of
Dustin Hoffman you bet
what unites these five best pictures is
that they probably represent the very
best of each person that is connected
with them Jimmy Connors once said when
he was asked how he won all those
tournaments he said I don't know I guess
I try a hundred and fifteen percent to
their hundred and ten percent
not all films make this attempt not all
people do these five films represent the
result of hundreds of people working
together a hundred and fifteen percent
to the fulfilment of a single vision the
the odds were against these five films
being nominated two of them took ten
years to get financed one was done by a
director her first effort after two
prime directors had turned it down you
have to break your heart to break
through those odds a few days ago an
editor working on a film that I just
completed said that there's a piece of
me in that cut there's a there's a piece
of my life in there everything I know
everything I've learned has gone into
this film to all the people to all the
directors the writers the producers the
actors to that crew which we never
forget once we've worked with them that
tribe of people who are so dedicated who
worked so many hours
who have given a piece of their life to
that particular film that we have worked
on to these five films that are being
honored tonight I am proud to be here to
join in honoring your efforts and your
grand achievement congratulations to all
of you
the nominees for Best Picture are
children of a lesser God in which love
is better unspoken Bert Sugarman and
Patrick Palmer producers
hannah and her sisters in which Woody
Allen finds sex in religion not
necessarily in that order
Robert Greenhut producer
the mission a powerful mixture of the
church and politics in the South
American jungle Fernando Chia geared
pardon me and David Puttnam producers
platoon youth and death in the Vietnam
War
Arnold Colson producer
a room with the view the beauty of
Florence and the passed through the eyes
of a young girl
Ismail merchant producer
and the winner is platoon
thank you very much I am deeply grateful
my profound thanks to John Daly and
Derrick Gibson for sharing my passion
for this property and giving me the
money to make it when all of this passed
and thanks also to Gerald green and
Orion Pictures and best Ron video and
golf tribe in ski for their support and
Richard Psalms for the completion
guarantee and Franz Hopkin of credit
lien--a for having the money in the
Philippine jungle when I really needed
it and to some other people autumn Anson
and Marian Billings and Anthea Jaffe and
to my wife Ann who has been my business
partner for 16 years and has been with
me every step of the way and to our
children Peter evident Stephanie for
urging me to make platoon because their
generation wanted to know more and today
all died and the entire cast and crew of
platoon for their dedication and
particularly Oliver Stone for his
brilliance I would not be here tonight
but for all of the stones brilliance and
I thank you Oliver
the power of the motion picture medium
is awesome platoon has brought to this
generation a new perspective of war that
war is not glamorous that it mains and
it kills and if perhaps platoon could
also influence people in this in other
countries of the world to hesitate
before they engage in war to demand
facts and ask questions before the bombs
then we not just those of us that may
platoon but the entire motion picture
industry will have succeeded beyond our
wildest imagination thank you so very
much
good night didn't I go all of you
wherever you live in this weary world
whatever your problems may be at this
moment go to a movie tomorrow and you'll
feel much better
that's padania Wayne is noches bonsoir
Oh about another thing what's another
good die thank him
question
we drop by trouble can save you time and
money paid to me
this is dr. Timothy guns later tonight
on Nightline can parents do more to
increase their child's and elegance or a
such pressure dangers those questions
tonight on Nightwatch
this is Charles Gibson tomorrow the
Academy Award winners join us on Good
Morning America tomorrow on Good Morning
America tomorrow at 9:00 8:00 central
and mountain will it be Dave and Maddie
or will it be Sam and Maddy find out
tomorrow on moonlighting then go 20
minutes into the future on the premiere
of Max Headroom and there's a place they
call Moriah premieres Wednesday at 10/9
central and mouthy
thanks for my skate
all eligible Academy members are asked
to vote for nomination for Best Picture
other nominations were voted by
what doesn't
results of the secret voting enough
Price Waterhouse until the seal and
motor
this is excellent student